Huh?
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August 1st,
uh,
2016.
How the hell are you?
How high is she going?
Hey G,
did he fight?
Hinge all trash.
80.
I'm in Dublin,
Dublin,
Ireland and uh,
I had my first couple of shows,
um,
last night and I was working,
believe it or not,
I was working outside in a fucking tent.
I don't have any of my podcast shit,
by the way,
if the sound is bad,
um,
I apologize.
I just,
the little mix of that I use every time I come over here,
even though I use the adapters and all that,
when I plug it in,
it just blows up my fucking thing.
Every time I've lost like two or three mixers doing that.
And then I got smart.
So now I just use this little portable fucking thing.
But anyways,
I um,
oh,
how the fuck is my password?
Come on
bill.
You can do with a,
we go,
there we go.
Ah,
Jesus.
I just fucked it up.
I'll fuck you.
I hate computers.
I fucking these,
this data still make you fucking life easier today.
You know what makes it easier where you're just like,
oh,
what kind of a fucking turtle is that?
You know,
that's where the good,
I can't,
I literally can't talk and do my password at the same time.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Fuck I gotta hit pause.
All right,
I'm back.
I got it.
Anyways.
Um,
so I performed in a tent and an air condition tent.
I flew halfway around the fucking world to perform outside in a tent.
So technically I was back inside that was not air conditioned.
It was fucking hot,
as hot as hell.
And my first show was like at four o'clock in the afternoon,
one of this,
this stranger's gigs.
It was still a great Gig,
but it was fucking bizarre.
And um,
I told them to close the door to the tent.
It was sort of like a structure,
you know,
one of those ones that you just put up and then they take it down and you're
like,
Hey,
wait,
you know,
like what the fuck that thing come from?
And then where the fuck did that thing go?
One of those,
you know,
Home Depot special.
So I told him to close the door because it was still broad daylight out,
you know,
and just comedy is like,
it's a fucking,
it's a nighttime,
dirty,
sleazy thing.
So I had them close the door and then like an asshole,
I'm bitching and go,
what the fuck is it?
So hot in here?
They had to give me like this giant like beach towel to wipe my fucking bald
head.
Oh fuck.
Um,
but I had a great time and um,
you know,
and I am not jet lagged,
it all.
Um,
I want to thank this,
uh,
well I don't get anybody in trouble,
but this person hooked me up with,
uh,
these little fucking things at Jamieson,
right?
Like these little bottles and uh,
you know,
I was going to be a good boy,
right?
So I fucking landed in Ireland.
Let me take you through the whole thing.
I fucking get on the flight,
right?
Air and English,
right.
Take off her day.
They are right.
And I get there and um,
blew all my money on a first class fucking ticket cause I'm not,
I'm not sitting in the back of the plane.
I'm an old man.
My back is fucked up.
So I just said fuck it.
I'm going to throw like 10 gigs out the window and plane tickets.
This was,
that's what I'm going to do.
It gives a shit.
Right.
So,
uh,
I show up.
It's one of those fucking folds all the way down into a bed seats.
So I am site right then there's fucking asshole.
I mean,
how can it can only go up from there,
right?
Oh,
I guess.
I guess it can go down.
It's,
I'm just saying it's like a perfect situation.
Oh,
hang on my fucking exit here.
All right,
I'm back.
You know what?
This is going to be breakfast with Billy.
Oh,
Billy.
Breakfast face.
Um,
so anyways,
I get on this fucking plane,
uh,
and I'm laying in a goddamn bed and they got Goodfellas.
Goodfellas is one of the movies that I can watch.
I'm like,
this is,
this is fucking perfect.
Nothing can ruin this.
And then this fucking cunt in front of me,
he's listening to his Bose headset.
So he's basically shut out the entire fucking world and he's listening to music
and he's humming along with it,
like in a tone deaf way.
So like he'd go like,
hmm.
And when like the music would go up,
like higher notes,
he wouldn't harm higher.
He just get louder.
It was just so,
ah,
I'm sitting there going,
how the fuck do I tell this guy politely to stop fucking Humvee?
I literally had I put earplugs in,
I could still hear the guy.
And I'm like,
why the fuck didn't I bought by the Bose headset to shut this fucking guy out?
Right.
So fortunately they started up the jet engines and I swear to God,
I could still fucking here this guy.
And uh,
then I,
I just,
I put on the movie and then I was fine.
So anyways,
so I started to watch Goodfellas,
you know,
my flight was like eight o'clock at night.
I start watching it and,
um,
I ended up,
I,
you know,
I hit pause cause I'm going to go to sleep.
I just fucking fall asleep.
Right.
And then I wake up with like,
we have like,
it's like a 10 hour flight.
I sleep for like eight hours.
I had already been on a plane for like an hour and a half.
We like 30 minutes left.
I watched a little more good fellas.
And then we landed to,
now it's like two o'clock in the afternoon.
I'm fucking wide awake.
I'm wide awake and all I'm thinking is just like,
I hate this now I'm going to be jet lagged,
I'm going to be up all night.
And uh,
I didn't have a show here in Dublin.
So what I did was,
um,
somebody who hooked me up and I want to say thank you to the person that gave me
these little Jamieson bottles,
right?
The 12 year fucking things and I wasn't going to drink or anything like that,
but it got to be like 11 o'clock at night and I'm like,
I am fucking wide awake.
This is going to suck.
I got to get on fucking Ireland time.
And I just came up with this idea.
It's like,
well,
you know,
if I drink in the afternoon,
I pass out and go to sleep.
So why don't I just start drinking?
So I'm alone in my hotel room and I just fucking pound these four bottles,
little bottles of the James Right now.
I'm nice and buzzed.
I start reading a book and write big Fridays.
I start getting sleepy.
I opened the curtains,
you know,
so the light would come in and spill in at like seven in the morning.
So I ended up falling asleep like around two,
three o'clock in the morning and then I was up at 7:00 AM
okay.
Does,
you know,
hung over or whatever.
That part sucked,
but it only took me a day.
Now I'm totally fucking acclimated.
Last night,
by the time I was done with my second show,
I was like totally fucking sleepy.
I was ready to pass out,
but I ran into Joe to Rosa and he's a drunk like me.
So we ended up going out.
I'll tell you the story in a second.
I gotta get these fucking ex,
hang on.
Alright,
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I need to fucking ex.
Um,
you know,
one thing I don't like about leaving the United States of America is the United
States of America,
the greatest country
on the planet as far as I'm concerned.
I just like saying that because people around the world get annoyed and like
part of them,
they know it's true.
You know?
It's true.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And only got going a couple hundred years ago,
but we caught up to alia,
we went right pasture and all you guys here with your history and your fucking
castles in your great walls,
you know,
none of that can compare to our strip malls.
You know,
it's true.
I know it's true.
Um,
I fucking hate bacon around the world.
The Best Bacon in the world is in the United States of America.
That is bacon.
This Canadian Bacon,
these slabs of fucking ham.
It's not bacon.
Or is this another one of those football fucking soccer arguments.
Maybe we're wrong.
Maybe we should not call it fucking bacon.
I don't know what it is.
But whatever we have in the United States,
it's fucking delicious.
And for whatever reason it's not served anywhere else in the world.
Yeah.
I don't know what you guys call it.
Is there something else?
Whatever the American style bacon is.
Do you call it something else?
And he's fucking God forsaken countries that,
Geez,
I got the hiccups.
I ate too fast.
They can't have,
you can't do a podcast while eating fucking eggs.
All right now hang on a second.
I got to go scare my scare myself.
Hang on.
It's only foster Brooks.
Yeah.
So if anybody,
anybody out,
they can tell me,
uh,
this podcast is going to be so fucked up cause I keep time traveling.
I just keep hitting pause and then going into the future,
um,
anybody can tell me.
Yeah,
what you call,
can I get that bacon over here and stop getting these slabs of fucking ham?
I don't know.
It's the little things.
It's the little things that you miss when you travel.
So anyways,
that's,
that's my new way where I'm going to beat jet lag.
That's how you do it.
You know,
instead of sitting there trying to fall asleep,
you just get shit faced and you pass out.
But before you get shit faced,
you open the curtains so then the sun will wake you up and it sucks the first
night you just going to feel like,
you know,
I mean I just felt like how I always do,
I woke up,
hung over,
wouldn't,
didn't get enough sleep
and then I was just,
I was fucking on it,
you know.
And um,
so I woke up and it was Sunday morning and Dublin and uh,
I decided I was going to walk around and,
um,
which is funny cause my cell phone,
you know,
the whole,
Google map thing isn't working over here.
So,
uh,
it's,
I just like,
uh,
when I was in,
before I left,
I,
you know,
I was on the hotel Wifi,
so I just,
my Google map thing was working and I just took a screenshot of where I was in
case I got lost and I could just jump in a cab or some shit.
So anyways,
I fucking just start walking around and,
uh,
like nothing is open.
I forgot it was Sunday.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
What's going on?
These people fucking all at home eating breakfast.
None of these places are open.
And I was just walking and walking.
I didn't realize,
you know,
it was like fucking 9:00 AM or some shit like that.
And on a Sunday,
and I already gone downstairs,
I'd already taken a steam.
They got a steam and a fucking pool and it was totally on fucking Dublin time.
And,
uh,
I just walked all around Dublin.
I was like on the other side down,
you know,
with that fucking horrific,
uh,
temple bar is where the fuck they call it.
The temple bar begins with a t that's every fucking jerk off American goes,
Ooh,
you go to Dublin,
you go to go down there.
And I went there the first time I came here and I go down there and I'm like
talking to some guy from Cincinnati.
I'm like,
I can fucking do this in the United States.
I don't want to be here.
Um,
everything's fucking overpriced.
So I walked on the other side of the river and I walked all the way up to their
park.
Uh,
it was called Phoenix,
the Phoenix Park.
Um,
I walked for three and a half hours.
MMM.
Just checking out this beautiful city and uh,
their park is fucking amazing.
And uh,
I got about halfway into it and then I realized they had a zoo and a,
I hate,
I fucking hate zoos.
I'm one of those people,
I don't like zoos.
I don't like sea world.
It's like,
will you let these things go?
You know what I mean?
Just let them go with the fact that a fucking God damn whale has like a matinee
show.
Like,
like the fact that like how does it kill a whale?
Like end up in show business,
you know what I mean?
And then they go and they kill their fucking trainers and it's just like,
yeah,
it doesn't want to be there.
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
we didn't see any erratic behavior and Bubbleq you didn't see any erratic
behavior.
You making the thing,
jump in the air and do somersaults and lay on its side and wave to people.
It doesn't even know what it's doing.
How do you get a fucking whale to do that other than starving it?
Or how do you beat the shit out of a whale?
I don't know what you do.
What do you electrocute him in the water?
Drop a fucking radio in there every time.
He doesn't go through the hoop.
Okay.
You know how many fucking trainers have to get attacked and killed before we
understand that these fucking people don't want to do it.
You know,
has the dancing clown like me ever attacked or murdered his fucking agent?
No,
because we want to,
cause it's,
we,
it was their own fucking choice to get into show business,
to make a fucking killer whale and a dolphin and,
and uh,
there was a little fucking sea lion thinks and if you all look,
he's waving at us.
No,
he isn't.
They don't understand the concept of way.
I mean,
they're doing the motion of waving.
They're doing that,
but that's so they'll still get food and not get the shit kicked out of them.
Especially like lions and tigers,
like how to fuck you get those giant,
how dumb are those cats?
You know what I mean?
That they just,
every fucking night they should just,
they should have to get a new trainer every night.
Like that should be the show.
Like the train,
it goes,
Yay,
get up on the box.
They just gets mauled and let's sit.
And then they just drag them out and bring another guy in.
This little fancy fucking sat and close lion tamer going in there with your
weapon,
your chair.
I never realized how fucking stupid that is.
I'm a lion tamer.
I'm gonna make that Lion Tamer.
Like fucking how insecure are you?
Okay.
Human beings have the fucking worse.
What does it bother you that,
that,
that it's a wild animal.
Okay.
What makes it an animal?
Wild.
Okay.
What really makes an animal wild?
The fact that it doesn't give a shit that you have socks and shoes on,
you know?
Is that what makes it wild?
That you know when you'd said,
well,
Hey,
get over there and set out.
It's like,
yeah,
go fuck yourself.
You know
the fuck Outta here.
I'll rip your face off.
Like to be,
that's not a wild animal.
That's,
that's an animal that has respect for itself.
Fuck Outta here.
Tell me what it said.
Where the fuck are you?
I'm faster than you.
I'm stronger than you.
I'll fucking kill you.
I won't even eat you.
I'll just fucking angia life.
How about I do that?
How about that?
How about you go over there and sit the fuck down?
You know,
I find love wild animals.
I just realize that you've got to respect them.
Ah,
man.
I was watching an awful fucking video.
The other nightmare,
just watching snakes eat other snakes and anything worse than that.
Fucking serpents all wound up around each other.
I fucking hate snakes.
I remember watching the Indiana Jones when I was a kid and I remember when he
fucking hated snakes.
I was just like,
I like this.
I relate to this guy.
You know,
he's flying around in planes.
He's trying to bang this bride and he doesn't like snakes.
He's got a nice leather jacket,
pulls off a hat.
You know what's not to like.
So anyways,
I'm why I'm watching this fucking video.
I don't get how like,
you know,
one of the snakes is poisonous and he's biting the other one in the back and the
thing's just fucking tank in it.
It's like,
what?
Yeah,
you're poison doesn't work on that thing.
Okay.
Oh,
you're so fucking nervous.
Like nothing's coming out.
That's gotta be the worst.
That's gotta be the worst thing ever as one of the snakes is eating the other
snake.
Right.
And he's,
he's fucking sucking them down and like this snake that's getting eaten,
the part of his body that's not in the other snake is still moving.
It's just going down the tunnel.
I know they're reptiles and they can't think,
but then somewhere on it even admits Reptilian head,
it's gotta be in their life like freaking the fuck out.
Okay.
Eaten alive.
It's gotta be the worst.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
I don't mean just like just brighten India.
At least she'd bleed out.
But if some just swallows you whole like that.
Yeah.
Just going down this fucking thing.
At what point do you run out of air?
Why isn't the snake that's going into the other snake?
That's when he should start biting them.
Fucking eat him from the fucking inside out.
Some reason that doesn't happen.
You know,
that's another problem in this election year.
Someone's needs to answer that question for me.
Hey,
you know what I'm really getting fucking tired of is the funniest fucking thing
ever to me.
And I'm not going to name any names.
I love when celebrities tell me who to vote for.
That's the stupidest fucking thing ever.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know if I should vote for Trump or for Hillary.
I can't make up my mind.
Oh,
wait a minute.
It's the guy from the dog whisperer.
Maybe he should tell him.
Oh yeah.
Who should I elect for?
Leader of the free world?
I'll tell you what is fucking hilarious to me.
It's not really hilarious,
but I actually,
I think I was,
I just met somebody when I was down in the,
uh,
I've took a steam,
right?
And then I went into the pool and I was shooting the shit with this guy.
And I'm telling you,
I think Trump could win.
I never thought I was just saying,
I go,
this is gonna be a fucking landslide.
No one's going to vote for this fucking dope.
Right?
And I'm running into this guy just got in these,
just sitting there going,
hey,
I can't fucking,
he's going,
I can't vote for Hillary.
She's a fucking criminal.
I'm going,
yeah,
but this other guy,
this guy's a dope.
Cause I agree with you.
The Hillary is a fucking idiot.
No,
I mean a criminal.
But this guy's like a fucking dope.
And he's got a,
you know,
but I think he just needs to shut up.
And I think he can get stuff done.
And this is,
this is the thing,
the human being in me.
All right,
the fucking,
I don't want to see Trump win.
Okay.
But I gotta tell you something.
Just living in Hollywood,
how fucking terrified they are that he's going to win.
It's worth it.
I just want to watch everybody just fucking freaking out.
It's going to be the like personal own selfish reasons.
If Trump gets elected,
like there's no place in the world,
you're going to want to be the next day then right in Hollywood in La and just
listen,
listen to them fucking losing their mind.
They literally think that that guy is going to take the entire country down.
Like it's possible for either Hillary
or Trump to do it.
You can't do it.
Fortunately,
the way our whole thing set up,
like,
you know,
if he'd get a couple of things done I guess is president,
it's a great thing.
But um,
if he had to bet right now,
like this would be such as like if this was a Superbowl,
yeah.
Um,
this is the hardest fucking,
how do you handicap this one there so fucking polarizing,
right?
You got Hillary Clinton,
Like,
like I,
I really feel like people in this country are,
are like,
maybe like,
I don't Clinton's and bushes.
I'm just sick of him.
I'm fucking sick of them,
right.
But I think there's enough people that fucking hate Hillary because they hate
Bill Clinton.
And then you got to also sexist people who just won't
vote for a woman.
And then you got women who will vote for just because she's a woman.
So maybe they'll cancel each other out.
And then he got Trump.
Who you know,
I want to say as a fucking dope,
but I mean the guy is a fucking billionaire,
right?
Is he though?
I don't know if he is.
Who the fuck he says he is?
I have no fucking idea.
Granted he did inherit the money,
but he also didn't fuck it up.
But he did go bankrupt.
I can't figure this fucking guy out.
I just can't believe these are my two choices.
I can't fucking believe it.
These,
this,
this is all time.
Fucking worst.
Worst fucking election ever.
How the fuck did we end up with these ds two fucking people?
You know what?
Maybe I will listen to the dog whisperer guy.
Maybe.
Maybe they can help me out.
I don't know what to do.
I don't have no fucking idea what to do.
There's no fucking way I'm voting for Trump,
but I'm not voting for somebody with 15 felony counts either.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
You know what's hilarious over here is fucking people like,
yeah,
people are freaking out about Trump over here.
They're like,
dude,
you can't fucking elect that.
You cannot have that guy be the leader of the free world.
And I'm like,
as when,
then what?
We're supposed to have the convicted felon.
I don't,
it's a fucking shit show people.
So anyways,
I dunno what the fuck they want.
You know,
it's fucking hilarious about me talking about all of this shit.
I have not watched one fucking,
I watched the first republican debate back when Trump was funny.
When you just like,
and this is hilarious at this,
this guy's running for president.
This is funny.
It's like if you,
you,
you fucking buddies like,
Hey,
I'll run for mayor.
And all of a sudden you see him on TV,
he's just laughing.
Watching him sounded like a fucking idiot,
you know,
and then,
then it's over.
And then you go back to the real world.
That back when he,
that's when I watched and then he kept winning and that was just,
it just stopped being funny to me.
So I stopped watching and I cannot listen to Hillary's fucking voice.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Like all,
it's,
it's uh,
I dunno,
I have no fucking idea.
You know what's funny is they give a shit more of a here about the election than
we do,
you know?
Do you know,
like when those fucking banker cons,
um,
those banker comes fucking,
uh,
in America when they totally cooked the fucking economy.
Like then,
cause everybody's like all tied in with each other.
Like that really affected the economy over here in Ireland.
I had no fucking idea.
I had no idea that that happened.
And like people over here got so despondent that the suicide rate went up and
everything like that.
And it just kills me because you know,
those bankers don't give a fuck.
They still sleep at night,
sleep soundly.
Yeah.
I'm telling you that is,
that is the candidate that I'm waiting for,
not the one that is going to say,
hey,
you know,
we need to fucking,
we need all kinds of reform and regulations in banking.
I don't want to hear that guy.
What we're beyond that.
I want to,
I want the guy that's going to be like,
look,
we need to kill a bunch of bankers.
Fucking start all over again.
That's,
that's my guy,
right?
I don't want,
I'm talking about,
let,
let me do a couple of live reads here.
All right.
I hope the sound is okay here.
23 fuck and minutes and,
all right.
Um,
frame.
Bridge.
All right.
You got an empty walls and you got something special you want to frame,
but she'd never do it because it takes too long and it costs too much money.
It's a fucking pain in the ass.
I hate doing that shit.
How much shit you got laying around going,
oh,
I'm going to get this frame.
What are you days?
I'm going to get it framed.
And you leave it there and then somebody steps on it.
Your dog takes a piss on it and then you just end up throwing it up.
You know,
and you want it.
They'll get it.
Frank,
look.
Anyway,
so let me,
let me get back to the copy.
Remember when cameras weren't part of your phone?
The way we takes pictures has changed,
but the way we framed them hasn't until now.
All right,
frame bridge.com is the easiest way to frame things you love from the treasure
trove of photos on your phone to posters in ad work.
Frame Bridge makes it easy and affordable.
Just go to frame bridge.com and pick out the frame you want or let their
designers help you choose.
You can even preview your item in any frame style.
They'll send you a prepaid package to ship your items safely,
or you can simply upload the picture to frame bridge site or an APP that this is
a fucking joke.
All right.
Right now,
if you go to frame bridge.com,
use the Promo Code Burr.
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame,
bridge.com Promo Code per frame,
bridge.com
Promo code birth.
There we go.
All right.
What am I doing now?
Track or everybody.
Smart cars,
smart phones,
smart homes.
Technology is everything.
Wicked smart dude,
but losing your stuff's still.
Make smart people feel really fucking dumb.
Track or makes losing things had tinkered a past tracker is that coin sized
Enphase located miss keys while it's bags,
computers,
any ting at hap for seven anything in seconds?
Just pair of tracker to your smartphone.
Attach it to anything and find his precise location with the tap of the button.
It's that easy.
Lose your phone.
Press the button on tracker.
I got to get this fucking thing.
I lose my phone all the Goddamn time.
I lost it last night and I'm like,
where the fuck is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I just talked to the lovely Nia.
I know it's in the room,
you know,
and slid down there,
but then I don't,
fuck,
I don't.
Then what if you lose the tracker thing,
lose your phone,
press the button onto,
okay,
we got that part with the level 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest
crowd gps network in the world.
So your last item shows up on a map,
even if it's miles away.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo Code Burr for 30% off your
entire order.
Again,
that's tracker.com tracker,
t r a C K e r.com Promo code birth.
Oh Jesus.
Here's the last one.
Here we go.
Well,
it'll do,
do me undies.
Me undies,
no more sweaty balls.
Doo,
Doo me undies.
Mandy's tidy,
tidy,
tidy each.
Who are going to do some Irish share stickers?
She'll Aly now on the fucking front.
Whack your nuts.
Nagio account.
If you go me undies,
the blood will dry up and you're blue balls will get healed.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats.
Um,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
you on your underwear,
it's probably just boring and beyond is here to change that with exciting new
fucking underwear.
Every pair of me undies has made from sustainable source modal modal of fabric
that's twice the softest cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies yet.
For some reason they're going to try to do it with this copy.
But once you try them on and you'll understand why they're called the world's
most comfortable underwear.
And if you,
that's who calls them the world's most comfortable underwear.
You guys,
that's like Detroit calling themselves hockey town.
What?
Because you say so.
The trade is not hockey town.
Okay.
It's a fucking bombed out God damn city.
Nothing about that city says hockey.
I'm sure when you get out to the outside areas they got a couple of ranks.
But when you're down there,
which you're really thinking is,
I don't want to die.
Um,
if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they're free.
No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear,
whether anyone sees them or not.
Um,
shipping is free and the United States and Canada.
And you save up to $8 a pair with the Mondays Dot Mondays subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when he got to me.
UNDIES dotcom.
Slash Burger.
That's me.
undies.com/ [inaudible] for 20% off your first order.
Uh,
[inaudible] dot com slash pat.
All right,
I'm done with that shit.
What are we up to?
28.
I got to go meet to Rosa.
He's over here.
Joey opened up for me.
Um,
all right,
three.
I got questions here to do.
All right,
let me run my mouth for like another fucking couple of minutes and then I'm
going to go meet up with old Joey.
Droz.
Um,
does Shelly,
she,
somebody gave me a fucking shall Eylea up to the show.
I never knew what it Shalala was.
For some reason I thought it was some sort of like fucking,
you know,
four leaf clover Leprechaun Shit.
Um,
evidently it isn't,
hang on a second.
You know what I'm going to tell Joe Rose,
I can't fucking meet him cause I gotta I gotta I gotta finish this podcast and
I'm going up to Belfast.
Hang on.
All right.
Just like dead,
just like dad,
I'm back more time travel here.
I'm not going to fucking,
I'm not hanging out with the Rosa trying to catch up with him tonight.
Um,
I'm going up to Belfast.
I've never been there.
And uh,
you know,
when I was growing up,
like all you heard all fucking crazy shit that was going on up there.
So my idea of is still a place that you,
uh,
you want to be on your best behavior.
I would think in general,
when you travel,
you're representing a country,
you want to be on your best behavior.
But when I was growing up,
all the violence and all the craziness and all that shit that I used to always
hear about,
um,
up in Belfast and everything.
And uh,
I dunno,
they were talking about Brexit or whatever the fuck are they talking about.
Um,
the UK leaving the European Union for whatever reason,
then that might become a hard border again and that could like raise tension and
all that shit.
It's just like fucking human beings,
man.
We just cannot get along.
I just want to go in there.
I want to have a great show.
And then I'm coming back down here to Dublin tonight.
Um,
and then I got Gallway the next day.
Everybody's telling me that's the most beautiful fucking city,
one of the most beautiful cities in the world.
And uh,
then I'm off to England.
Oh,
this fucking cunt man.
When I,
when I landed,
they gave me these,
these,
these work papers.
So when you land,
you know,
show this to customs,
do not say you're just over there to be a tourist,
right?
Just fucking given the work papers.
So I said,
fine,
right?
And I land and I've fucking Ireland.
I give it to the guy and the guy goes,
what sis?
And I said,
oh,
they told me to show,
show you my work papers.
I'm working over here,
I'm doing some standup shows.
And the guy goes to says a UK,
Ireland is not part of the UK.
I just want to be like,
I know that she a fucking con.
My person told me to show it to you,
but you can't say that because then they'll send you back to the United States.
I it'd be like,
oh,
okay.
I didn't realize that.
Oh,
I didn't,
I didn't know what to fucking UK was.
She's fucking Christ.
What is the UK?
It's a fight.
It's,
it's Northern Ireland,
England,
Wales and fucking,
uh,
Scotland,
right?
Isn't that what the fuck it is?
I gotta look it up now.
Here I am calling this guy.
Can't I actually,
I might get this wrong.
United Kingdom.
It's kind of a big fucking word for fuck's a small area,
you know?
And they get used to be,
they need to do with just that,
you know,
like the way Jefferson airplane did,
then they became Jefferson star ship because it was more into the future.
Right.
All right.
Hang on a sec.
They,
they need to dial this down.
United Kingdom.
When he had all this shit around the world,
then it should have been United.
Uh,
no.
I don't know what the fuck you'd call it.
And maybe that's why they didn't necessarily know about,
wait a,
come back down.
Sorry.
I'm trying to fucking read this shit.
What is it?
Population?
Nobody cares.
Okay.
Northern Ireland.
Okay,
great.
Okay.
The United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland,
commonly known as the United Kingdom.
How come he don't fucking talk about Scotland?
Like it's its own deal.
I don't get it.
Okay.
I always thought like they were subjects.
Of fucking like Britain went up and took them over,
but they still were kind of their own deal.
Is it in Scotland,
Scotland and then fucking England's England.
Okay.
The different people that different nationalities,
they don't fucking like each other.
Right
then.
Not English,
this Scottish.
Why do they just get all swallowed up by this shit?
I don't understand it.
They don't even bring them up.
They talk about Northern Ireland.
They don't even mention Scottish people.
You know what I,
this guy was right to yell at.
Now you know what,
I take that back.
That guy was not a con,
that fucking,
it was a good con.
He was a top con.
He fucking hit the nail on the head.
That's exactly what he did.
Um,
so anyways,
so I walked all around Dublin.
I'm sorry about this podcast.
It means it's all over the place.
Who the fuck's Kyp know?
Um,
so I walked all around Dublin and saw all this,
you know,
I'll,
I'll this shape,
right?
And uh,
and then when I get back,
you know,
the Formula One race comes on at one o'clock in the afternoon out here as
opposed to four 30 in the fucking morning.
You know,
I got to record it and then try not to go online and see anything,
you know?
And,
um,
so now I would come back and now I'm starting up.
The jet lag is getting to me.
I'm starting to feel sleepy and everything.
And,
um,
I fucking a,
I,
I took an hour nap.
I did take an hour nap before my shows,
but a,
so I was listening to the,
Oh,
I watched some of the Formula One and then I fell asleep.
And anytime anybody went to pass anybody,
the guy would start screaming and then I would wake up.
So I did see most of the exciting parts of the fucking race.
MMM.
Fucking Nico.
Jesus Christ,
he fight,
he keeps getting the pole position.
He fucks it up in the first turn.
And it's nothing to,
I don't get like,
it just seems like
Formula One racing as far as what I've watched.
The race is just to the first turn.
Whoever comes out in front of that turn wins the fucking race it seems.
Or at least if Lewis Hamilton gets to the fucking first turn,
he comes out of there in first place.
It's over.
He just cruises for the entire fucking,
uh,
the entire race.
A Nico,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck was he doing?
Spinning the tires and all his shit and everybody just fucking went right around
them.
Okay.
And he's got to spend how he's got to spend the whole fucking race just trying
to get back into second place.
And he did what he always does.
He goes fucking went into a corner,
tries to pass on the inside and he just forces the guy to the outside.
Then he gets a fuckup penalty,
but somebody did it to him a few fucking races ago.
There's something about this kid they don't like.
They don't like it.
You fucked him over.
So he wasn't even on the pole,
that podium.
So now,
uh,
Lewis Hamilton,
it's like a head by like 40 points.
I don't know.
Still.
It's a great fucking,
I was actually thinking,
you know,
because Germany is only a couple hours away that what I should it now.
I had an afternoon show.
I still couldn't have done it.
I was thinking like I should have just flown directly to Germany,
gone to that thing,
right.
Then jumped on a plane,
come back here and done my Sha.
What if my James Bond,
I couldn't pull that off.
You need your own fucking plane to do that.
Like all those people in the stance,
Formula One,
those people are filthy fucking rich.
It's actually not true.
Actually looked up at for tickets.
You can get a ticket for like 55 bucks.
You get your face pressed up against the screen and if anybody crashes,
you're going to die.
But you're going to be there.
You're going to be there for 55 bucks.
You can make it happen.
All right,
I'm sorry.
Let's,
let's get to some of the questions here for the week.
Oh,
by the way,
I walked through the creepiest God damn park.
Um,
the fuck am I Marion Park or some shit?
You know,
it's beautiful when there's people there,
but I got up at seven in the morning.
There was like nobody there and uh,
I don't know what it was.
It just had it just ate the fucking park,
creep me out.
And,
uh,
some Weirdo guy sitting there
and then they had this really weird statue of this guy.
This self satisfied can't just sitting on a fucking rock.
You know,
I took a picture of it.
Hang on a second.
Okay.
Right.
Why don't know why the fuck would I shut my phone off?
Oh,
I didn't.
Okay.
I just took a screenshot.
All right.
Hang on a second.
What is this guy's name?
Yeah.
What is his name?
Oh,
Ireland's yet another fucking place.
You know where I can buy a Cuban cigar lit.
There's no place to smoke the fucking thing.
Oh,
you can walk down the street,
walk down this,
I'm not a fucking animal.
I'm smoking a cigar like those fucking cigarette smokers,
you know,
standing next to a dumpster there.
Animal cigarette smokers are fucking animals.
They really are.
All right.
Yeah,
it was Marine Square Park.
All right.
And then I took a picture of a,
they have the blue tit and the green tit bird.
I swear to God there this day or this whole fucking thing on all the different
birds.
They tried to claim that there was a fox in there and all this shit,
you know,
and you show up,
you don't see anything.
You see that black and white bird,
that's all you see.
Oh there he is.
Okay.
You got a,
you know what?
I'm going to post this picture.
This guy is,
it's got to the,
I don't know if the person didn't like this guy.
Is it Oliver Wilde?
I have no idea who he is easier at another one of these fucking clever Irish
cunt fucking writers.
You know what I mean?
Where they're like,
you know,
I ah,
these fucking overdramatic quotes.
I was reading one where the guy said,
uh,
centered.
If he could go back and be young again,
you know,
he wouldn't do it cause he's,
he's so fucking cynical or [inaudible] I can't remember what the fuck it was
like,
oh,
shut the fuck up.
You fucking miserable content.
Jesus Christ just staring into the misery.
Can you show me some light?
I don't understand it.
Oh my God,
you guys got to see this picture.
Um,
I'm definitely fucking post in this thing.
Yeah.
That guy is the epitome of a cozy smug content,
as they say over here.
He looks like he's,
I don't even know what he looks like.
He just looks like a,
you ever watch like a movie and there's just the evil guy and when he's on trial
he just has this look on his face.
Like he's going to get away with it.
That's what he looks like.
Like his dad's going to buy him out and he's got this crooked fucking smile.
Dumb ass fucking loafers.
Um,
all right,
let's get to the questions here for the week.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
Jesus.
He's a big question of will I ever get laid.
Okay.
All right,
dear bill,
I'm currently in an emotional quandary.
I'm 19 and I've never been laid.
That's not bad.
Said I was homeschooled my entire life by strict religious parents.
All right.
That's bad.
Who Shield maiden shielded me from girls?
My sister who is 21 years old,
was my only window to the female world.
She would always have female friends around and many of them hit on me.
I even made out slash felt up.
One of them.
So you're in the game.
He scored a couple of buckets.
You're on the scorecard.
Uh,
he said,
which was my only sexual experience ever.
So although sheltered,
my outlook is bright,
right?
And he says,
wrong.
Three years ago I mysteriously developed severe social anxiety to the point I
can barely go to public places.
Around this time my parents kicked my sister out of the house because she left
Christianity.
Oh yeah,
that's inevitable.
So she moved in with the friend.
So now not only am I paralyzed with anxiety,
but now the well has dried up since she left.
And I have no female circulating around in my life.
This is how my life has been since 2013 and I don't know how many more years of
it I can take.
I'm not at the point,
I'm not at the point where,
yeah,
I think you meant to say I'm now at the point,
right?
Where,
what do I do?
Um,
I would,
I would deal with your social anxiety first.
I mean,
your parents allow you to go outside,
right?
So what I would do is you just,
you know,
just give yourself some small goals,
just go out,
go to the store,
go buy something and come home.
That's it.
Do that.
He just gradually increase outcome.
It's like flying and you get your pilot's license,
which you do is you just keep gradually increasing this,
the area that you're familiar with and comfortable flying it.
You know,
you don't just get your pilot's license and just fucking,
just start flying all over the fucking place.
You're nervous,
you're scared,
right?
So you just gradually keep increasing the,
uh,
your area.
So that's what I would do.
And then once you get comfortable with the area,
then,
uh,
then you add more shit to it.
There's a woman behind the counter sale,
oto or some shit,
little things,
and dude,
you're gonna be fine.
The fact that you're living under those severe conditions and you still made out
with a chick and felt her up,
I me,
dude,
you're crushing it.
You're being way too hard on yourself.
You're only 19.
You got your whole life ahead of you,
you know,
telling you you're in a great position.
Just,
you know,
just work on it a little bit.
You'll be fine.
You'll totally be fine.
And the fact that you know,
she's bringing these girls over there and they're fucking hitting on you.
I mean the you that never happened to make women now my God,
I had to spin plates and fucking all kinds of shit to try to get them to pay
attention to me.
So you're,
you're way better in a way better situation than I was when,
um,
when,
uh,
when I was 19.
So just know that you know,
people always have it worse than you.
Just go easy on yourself.
You'll be fine.
Probably get laid by the time you fucking 20.
Just go out and say hello to people,
right?
You got women coming over,
throwing themselves at you.
I mean,
I don't even know.
Am I supposed to feel bad for you?
I want to be you.
You're 19 and he got women hitting on you.
Dude.
You're a fucking rock star.
All right.
Tired of line.
Hey Billy nut buster.
Here's my situation.
I've been mildly depressed.
Jesus Christ.
Here we go.
Everybody seven.
No problem.
This week I've been mildly depressed from my whole life and struggled with an
identity crisis since my early teens.
What the fuck is an identity crisis?
Hang on a second.
What do you look in the mirror and be like,
who the fuck's?
Oh,
that's right.
That's me.
Sorry.
Hold on.
All right.
You know,
I just realized how funny this is.
I'm sitting there going like,
I hate when like celebrities to try to tell me who I should vote for.
And here I am fucking giving you guys advice,
but don't you guys ask me for advice because you think you know I'm going to say
something stupid.
Um,
this is just part of your entertainment,
isn't it?
All right.
Identity crisis.
The term identity crisis coined by the psychologists.
Erick Erickson.
That's a real name.
My name is Bill Bilson.
This is,
uh,
my buddy here.
Pete Peterson.
Um,
means the failure,
failure to achieve ego identity during adolescence.
Yeah.
Well,
what the fuck does that mean you don't achieve ego identity?
I think that's a definition
that's a fucking enigma wrapped up in a rental,
right?
The stage of psychological development in which identity crisis may occur,
and then now you're just going to fucking move on.
None of those fucking words are highlighted.
Am I?
Am I the only dumb ass who doesn't know what that means?
During this stage,
Adam adolescents are faced with physical growth,
sexual maturity in integrating ideas of themselves,
about what others think about themselves.
Oh,
hey,
you are explaining it.
Sorry.
I panicked.
Adolescents therefore form their self image and an ender.
The tasks of resolving the crisis of their basic ego identity.
Oh,
so just means you're trying to figure out who you are.
Okay,
well,
who the fuck knows that at that age?
All right.
Let me get back to the fucking question here.
Well,
where's the question?
Did I that I,
I didn't open a new window.
Oh boy.
All right,
here we go.
I'm straighten it with the identity crisis.
Since my early teams,
all this,
thanks to my shitty upbringing.
I am Canadian,
but growing up I've always been fascinated with American culture and so on.
So some Ui and our bacon to our Becky,
you know,
say what you want about,
our foreign policy,
you can't fuck with our bacon.
So some years ago in my late teens,
I'm now 27,
I began to cultivate this lie that I was American.
I fucking love this guy.
Why would you do that?
This is fascinating.
And so on to the point,
my friends and girlfriends friend believe this,
I've gone as far as to legally change my last name,
lie about my heritage partly and a few other things.
My European girlfriend now believes full heatedly.
How'd you mean heartedly full heatedly in my life and her family and friends to
it started by accident coming out as the casual lie.
Uh,
it is before we dated.
However,
I am now in a very amazing relationship with her and I loved this girl very much
in planning the her.
Unfortunately she has trust issues and me being American is part of my appeal.
I'm sure.
Oh God,
dude,
what did you do?
She doesn't take to liars are lying lightly at all.
Also we're planning on starting a business together and so on.
This lie would come out eventually.
Right now I'm in Canada for a couple of months and she's in Europe.
I'll see her again soon.
And I'd prefer to break the news face to face,
not on the phone.
This lie is weighing really heavy on me and I want to tell her,
but I feel that if I lost her,
I couldn't carry on in life.
My depression is getting worse with this distance for a few months in the weight
of this lie.
By the way,
this isn't a long distance relationship.
I live over in Europe too.
I want your advice on how to break the news to her.
I love to hear your thoughts on the podcast.
A yeah.
Did you gotta
you gotta fucking,
you just got to face the music here.
Um,
yeah,
I would just sit her down and just say,
listen,
I have something I have to tell you.
Uh Oh God.
And that's gonna make her fucking heart drop.
But you got to do it.
I didn't cheat on you.
I'm not breaking up with you.
I would say that first.
Okay.
It's a,
you know,
something about me.
I don't have cancer.
Uh,
and you just said she'd be like,
what the fuck is it?
And you gotta be like,
listen,
um,
I lied about being an American.
There you go.
And then it's out there and then after that it's going to naturally go its
course.
That's all you have to do.
I lied about being American.
I lied about being Americans.
Five fucking words,
five fucking words.
And this weight is off your chest.
Now how she reacts to it and all of that other stuff is different.
I would just be totally honest with her and just say the weight of this,
the reason why I did it.
I didn't like myself.
The identity crisis.
Just tell her why you did it.
Yeah.
And um,
then I don't know what you do after that other than just wait to see her
reaction to it.
MMM.
I knew somebody one time that lied about their age
and uh,
it was nuts.
He was dating this person for a number of years and she was much younger.
So he started out the relationship by saying he was,
he was younger.
And then I remember like when he started introducing her to us,
the few times he did,
he was going like,
listen a be like,
just,
yeah,
we went to high school together,
but we didn't graduate in 1987.
We graduate
like 1993.
And we were all sitting there laughing and I'm going like,
dude,
I can't remember all this shit.
How about I just,
I don't bring up high school.
I just won't bring up any years.
And we just,
we basically hammered this guy
forever and then he finally came clean.
And you know what dude?
He came clean and she didn't break up with them.
Okay.
She didn't fucking break up with the women are way more forgiving than,
uh,
than men are.
I think they,
their,
their capacity to forgive is much greater.
So what's funny was this guy finally came clean.
She freaked the fuck out.
But then she forgave him and then they stayed together.
And then six months later he dumped her.
So,
okay,
figure that one out.
So dude,
you'll be fine.
Just tell her you got to tell her,
you know,
and um,
no matter what,
dude,
you're going to survive this whole fucking thing of like,
oh my God,
if this person leaves me a,
my life's going to be,
it's not going to be over.
Okay.
And she probably won't leave you.
You know,
she loves you two,
you'll be fine.
But you know,
just
okay,
the big thing,
all you got to worry about duty,
she just got,
you just got to get this fucking lie off your chest and you know what dude?
Then you can fucking breathe again and uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's going to be weird for a while,
but you know,
it's a situation you created and as a man,
you got to fucking deal with it.
All right,
so good luck to you.
All right.
My girl wears entirely too much makeup.
Oh,
Billy fire crutch.
I've been dating a girl for three years who was fantastic,
fantastic.
She's caring.
She's carrying,
listens to me bitch about work and is
okay.
A crazy lunatic in a good way.
In the SEC.
All right,
so she's great and bed and she puts up with you.
What's,
what's the not like my one problem is that she wears way too much makeup.
She watches youtube videos all the time dealing with ways to put on makeup,
but she always looks like she uses too much.
Her eyebrows look kind of like Groucho Marx by the end of it.
My dilemma is how do I go about telling her nicely that she,
she should ease up on the makeup.
She's very sensitive about our looks.
Yeah,
I would guess that,
but also values my opinion,
which is why I'm in a tough spot.
I kind of feel like a jerk too,
because if this is my one problem than I should be able to deal with it.
Right.
Uh,
the lovely Nia should probably weigh in on this.
also,
if she's not asleep,
thanks and go fuck yourself.
Unfortunately she's not here.
Yeah,
I would just,
uh,
I dunno,
one time when she's not wearing makeup,
just tell her how pretty she looks.
Didn't just tell her that you love the way she looks.
Okay.
You know?
Yeah.
Just start there.
Gradually build up or fucking confidence and uh,
I dunno how you could ever just say,
you know what,
you wear too much makeup if you just said it just
okay.
I uh,
how,
how would you say,
well,
let's get to the truth of the matter.
You're obviously attracted to are you obviously think she's beautiful but she
wears soon.
So much makeup.
Yeah.
If a woman wears too much makeup,
they can start looking crazy.
Then also,
you know,
they give you a hug and it's just like you have like the imprint of their face,
you know what I mean?
Is I call the stigmata.
What's the thing when you have fucking Jesus's face on you at Christ?
I always have to look.
I know many times I fucking looked up this word,
so fucking great song too.
That's stigma.
Alright.
Stigmata
okay.
Is a term used?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
This is all this religious,
it's a term used by members of the Christian faith to describe body marks,
sores or sensations of pain and locations corresponding to the crucifixion
wounds of Jesus Christ,
such as hands,
wrists,
and feet.
I'll give me a fucking break.
What is,
what the fuck is wrong with people?
Oh,
Jesus is in me and my hands fucking hurt.
I mean,
can you fucking imagine Lynn?
Let's say,
let's just fucking say,
okay.
For the sake of fucking argument that Jesus Christ was a real person and that
shit happened to him.
For you to fucking sit there and be like,
oh my fucking hands hurt.
You know?
Do you realize how insulting that is?
Yeah.
To,
to,
to fucking Jay star there.
You know this guy had fucking nails.
Okay.
Isn't it?
In his arms.
And he did it to his hands.
The weight of his fucking body.
They would have ripped off.
Then they actually do it in the fucking risks between the radius and the Ulna.
The fucking agony that this person went through.
And you're going to fucking sit there.
Oh yeah.
I kind of feel it.
Two,
how fucking self centered are you?
Um,
all right,
so she wears too much makeup.
Yeah,
I would just say,
uh,
yeah,
I would just tell her how pretty she is,
you know?
Okay.
And rather than saying you wear too much makeup,
I would more phrase it like,
you know,
you don't have to wear all that makeup.
Yeah,
yeah.
She'd show the world your beautiful face,
you covering it up.
So I would,
I would go on a very positive way,
you know,
but I would just,
I would just ease into,
I would just,
when she's not wearing makeup,
you just keep telling her how pretty she looks,
you know what I mean?
Um,
yeah.
And then hopefully she'll get past it because that's a sad thing.
If someone's walking around,
they don't like how they look.
Um,
I don't know.
People are fucking nuts people.
I think the Internet makes people even more fucking nuts.
Just sitting there looking at all these people,
at least Instagram people and all this fucking shit.
Just,
it tries people.
Eco,
you get a little crazy.
Um,
all right.
Podcast topics slash hopefully.
Interesting thought.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you wrote a God damn novel here.
All right,
I'm going to apologize up front for my bad reading here.
Alright,
here we go.
Hey Bill.
Um,
are you up for something a little bit different?
Who writes set?
It's not about football and if it's a conspiracy theory,
it's one for the future.
I bet you didn't think making pie would be something interesting to you.
But look at you now with the butter crust and everything.
So give it a shot.
Ah Ha.
Well Dude,
I'm fucking read it.
You don't,
you don't get to write all that stuff.
I'll read anything.
All right.
Would you ever tell a port somewhere if the technology got to that point?
It was something I thought would be cool until you see the difference ways
they're trying it,
trying it out.
Who is the first is a wormhole,
which is some kind of space time anomaly that I don't even think the physicist
understands.
Okay.
Physicist to understand.
I don't understand what I,
you've already lost me.
This would be pretty cool,
but it is obviously especially unlikely to ever be a thing.
Do,
would you look at this sentence?
This would be pretty cool,
but as obviously a specially unlikely to ever be a thing.
Okay.
It was like fucking left and right.
Turns it in.
Just in that sentence.
Another way they are looking.
Oh by the way,
I,
you know,
I never understood why Formula One was looking down on like Indy car racing and
stock car racing.
How it's just left turns just left turns,
just left turns like why it's harder that there's left and right turns.
I finally noticed.
Cause what happens is,
is that if there's a left turn and you're on the inside and you get past the guy
and then the next turns a right turn,
then he's on the inside.
So it's,
it's actually way more difficult.
You think.
You think,
you know stock car racing,
you get on the inside then yeah,
that's it.
You passed the guy.
Okay.
Then he's got to try to get inside of you or maybe fucking have somebody draft
behind him or whatever.
But I mean,
there's only so many fucking ways you can go formula one race and you're like,
yeah,
I fucking passed.
Ya know,
I did son of a bitch.
Right.
Um,
sorry.
That was way over simplifying something really difficult.
All right,
let's get back.
I just needed a break from that last sentence.
All right.
Another way they're looking into this
okay.
Is Really fucking horrifying.
The idea is that they can break you down.
Okay.
You're Adams while analyzing exactly how everything was connected and just put
the same elements together on the other side.
This could even work with your brain and memories.
Okay.
What really all of our consciousness is just neurons in certain patterns
connected uniquely in each of us based on our DNA and experiences.
Yeah.
Dude.
Like already,
I can tell you this,
like,
you know,
you go to Jiffy Lube and their job is literally to change the oil drain oil out
and then put other oil n and the amount of times that they forget to put it in
and the person drives away without the oil in there and then the engine seizes.
You know what I mean?
You think I'm going to go to fucking the Jiffy Lube of teleporting
and I'm gonna roll the dice that they're going to get everything back together
again anyways.
He says,
obviously this would be something in the distant future,
but aren't you technically dying every time you go through that?
Go through what a clown.
Oh wait.
If you were to teleport and a clone with the same memories comes out on the
other side.
It's a weird thought that if this ever became a thing,
everyone using it to communicate every day would be dying twice a day with the
clone coming out on the other side.
Yeah.
Dude,
this sounds like a great movie.
It,
it's fucked up enough that no one else like friends or family would know the
difference,
but even you slash clone,
you wouldn't.
If it was good enough that all of the memories came with you,
the clone would just come out the other side.
Remembering stepping in the receiver a minute ago,
even though the version of you that experienced that is dead now.
Yeah,
so what?
Your soul would know it.
Wherever the fuck your soul goes and you'd be standing down,
you know,
looking down from a cloud or wherever the fuck you go.
Go on that motherfucker isn't me walking around big in me.
And he goes,
he goes,
sorry if I,
if I got too weird for you,
but I thought if I experienced,
explained it right,
this would be at least mildly inches.
Totally interesting.
Um,
even they had that,
even if they had the technology right now,
I feel like they would have to slowly work up to this.
Like everyone thought if he had a cell phone,
you reduced,
then everyone had one.
Now we have like,
now we have shit like Pokemon go every,
can I get the rest of this stuff though?
This is,
I thought about,
you know,
when I was in my early days of traveling,
basically the first 20 years of this shit and I took,
you know,
buses and sat in the back of the plane and all of that type of shit.
MMM.
I remember just thinking that,
uh,
I just wished that I,
I,
I remember wishing that I had an f 16
you know,
and a pilot and that we could somehow fly like whatever,
2000 miles an hour,
whatever that is,
mock whatever
across the country and I could get across the country and like an hour and a
half
it just fucking in the thing and have
the guy just push the stick forward.
Whoa.
That's,
that was my big thing.
I was into bullet trains.
I was into all of this shit and when I fucking hated was whenever I took the
train from Boston down to New York City,
they had the high speed fucking train and it would go high speed to like
Stamford,
Connecticut or some shit.
And then they had to stop and change the engine.
So just slow the fuck down.
Something like that.
You'd have to stop and you'd get behind the slow one.
It just,
it didn't even make any fucking sense to pay all that extra money.
And all you did was shave like 20 minutes off the thing.
So
I've always thought about like,
I,
I would just use teleporting for travel,
you know,
but,
um,
I agree with you that you,
you,
you are tech,
you would be dying if they took you completely apart.
Like
that is weird.
Like what the f what,
what,
what exactly would you be like your heart would be completely taken apart.
First of all to this no fucking way we're ever going to learn how to do that.
There's no way teleporting and time travel and all that shit.
If,
if we were going to learn how to do it,
we already would've known about it.
You know what I mean?
Cause someone would have done in the future and they would've come back and
somebody would have said something,
hey,
not for nothing.
I'm from fucking 2152.
Just wanted to come back here and uh,
you know,
just wanted to breathe better,
better air and get away from all those robots,
you know,
that are running the fucking world.
Um,
all right,
girlfriend leaving.
Yeah.
All right,
dear bill.
Love the podcasts.
All right.
My girlfriend and I have lived on Long Island.
Our whole lives go jets,
go islanders and in a couple of weeks she's moving out to the Midwest.
So their family,
uh,
I knew I was going to see her a lot less since we're starting at different
colleges in the fall,
but I figured we could still give it a go when we come back during breaks and
stuff.
She's,
my first real girlfriend lost her virginity is teach others other and whatnot.
And I don't know,
man,
this really sucks.
I'm still crazy about her.
Like to the point where I'm seriously thinking about transferring to another
school next year in a likely futile attempt to keep the dream alive.
I know,
I know.
Call me an idiot,
but hey,
I'm a dumb teenager.
I don't think you're an idiot.
You love the girl.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Uh,
this is supposed to be the prime of our lives and I get that,
but I just don't want it to end with her.
You know,
any advice from you or the lovely Nia on how to make long distance work or
moving on in general would be greatly appreciated.
Um,
this is what she gotta do.
You gotta allow yourself to be the age that you're at.
Okay.
You don't have the answers to these questions.
They're really aren't any,
each person is unique.
The two of you are unique and all you can do is just tell her how you feel.
I hope she feels the same way and there's nothing more you can do.
You know,
it's either going to work out or it isn't.
And I'm,
you know,
you just have to accept in life that most shit is out of your control and you're
going to have good days.
You can have bad days,
you're going to have happiness and you're going to have pain.
And you know,
when you go through painful parts of your life,
you just,
you have to face it and you have to,
uh,
you have to accept it.
You're not special as far as like,
you know,
you're not going to go through life and not get you.
Everybody's going to get their fair share of heartache every was going to get
there.
Hopefully their fair share of happiness.
So you know,
you're still young.
You got your whole fucking life ahead of you.
Like I said,
all you can do is just tell this woman how you feel and uh,
if it works out,
it works out.
If it doesn't,
it does it.
I can also tell you that,
you know,
you're going to be going to a college and there's going to be a bunch of
beautiful women there.
There's going to be,
college is the greatest fucking nightclub,
like ever,
ever.
You know,
you walk into a nightclub,
it's like,
you know,
the women know why the fuck you there.
So there's,
they already got their guard up when you go to college,
you know,
you're going there to go to school.
So everybody's a little more fucking relaxed.
Yeah,
you can go there and you just fucking hit on all of them.
Every fucking one.
Women that are completely out of your league,
just fucking have a good dude.
You're fucking,
oh,
I guess you're not single.
You have this girl,
but I'm just saying if she fucking dump,
shoot dude,
like you're depressed.
Your depression,
right,
of the life that you're going to have after that is you're basically going to be
a single guy in the prime of your life going to college.
Like that's not a big dropoff.
You know,
you're totally going to be fine.
So like I said,
just tell this woman how you feel.
If she feels the same way at a workout.
If it doesn't,
then you're a free man at college.
And I could tell you this right now as a married guy,
I can tell you some day you'll be married and you'll have kids and you're going
to look back when you were single in college with all of those fucking women
around and you,
you,
you don't want to look back on what the fuck was I thinking?
I'm not saying going out there and being a fucking man whore,
but go out,
have a good fucking time.
You know,
dude,
you're single and Co.
If you end up being single in college,
the thing that you're kind of afraid of because you don't want to lose this
woman.
This is your basically your drafting in the first round.
Do you know what I mean?
Like there's so many great catches cause they're all fucking single so you can
go out and you can,
you can get,
you can get a quality,
quality fucking woman if you're single and you're in college,
you know,
the older you get,
you start drafting.
Then the later rounds,
you know you start,
you know,
you start meeting women with shoes,
women with fucking baggage.
All the great ones get fucking snapped up.
So you know
she's single and make your thirties.
That's when all of a sudden you think he got a number one draft pick and then
all of a sudden you know,
you end up with like a Greg Oden situation.
Right.
She got some fucking micro fractures in her feet or some shit or a niece.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm just saying like,
like at your age,
you know,
the hardest thing is you haven't,
you,
you haven't been older yet.
Like all the people look would look at your situation and just be like,
dude,
you're in a fucking dream situation.
Um,
but there's,
I,
there's no way for me to explain that to you because you'd have to be old and
get married and,
uh,
just be going through the fucking,
the relationship shit.
You know,
it's just the fucking ups and downs and ups and downs and like,
now you're fucking legally bound to somebody,
which is fucking insane to begin with.
And the fact that you're just as you just single,
you can do whatever the fuck you want to do within reason.
And I don't mean like,
you know,
he can't go out and buy a yacht.
You don't have the money to do that.
But I'm just saying that you,
you just,
whatever you feel like doing,
you could basically go do it.
And,
um,
the thing that I really wish when I was single that I appreciated more was that
level of freedom.
And then also I wish somebody older.
Okay.
Could have told me,
like really just could have told me like I lucked out with Nia,
but like summit,
some of the other people that I dated and stuff like that,
I mean,
granted it was also 50% me.
Like,
like the level of shit that I put up with when I was younger.
Um,
you know,
I wish I had like more self esteem,
like,
um,
this is obviously for men and women listening to this shit.
Like
if you're with somebody and they a fucking asshole,
like why would you waste another second of your life with them?
You know what I mean?
Trying to find reasons to stay with a person.
It's like,
this person is a fucking asshole.
Okay.
However you're wired and however they're wired,
it's not working.
Fuck off,
fuck off.
Get out of my fucking life and just walk away from it.
I mean,
I,
I learned that so late in life and like I said,
I just lucked out when I met Nia.
But like,
I,
um,
I had friends in my life that were just fucking assholes.
And I just remember one day I just woke up and you're like,
I really shouldn't have to work at being friends with somebody.
Like this is like work.
I got to sit there and worry.
How is this person coming at when he and it just,
and then I just got him out of my life and then I just Kinda just,
I dunno,
came up with some sort of like standard that if someone dip below it,
that that was it.
They were out,
you fucking off the team and now I,
you know,
I got all these great friends in my life.
I don't have to fucking solid people.
That's essentially what you look for.
I know I'm getting off the beaten track here,
but dude,
like you,
you got you.
You're in a dream situation.
Whether this works out or it doesn't,
you know,
and also as much as it hurts,
if you get your heartbroken,
it's good to get one of those out of the way.
So you're all good.
You're all fucking good.
I wouldn't worry about shit.
Tell her how you fucking feel.
And she that fucking accepts the fact that you're a number one draft pick or she
doesn't.
If she doesn't,
it's,
that's her fucking loss and you move on.
You go to college,
you fucking crush it.
There you go.
Alright,
that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Thank you to everyone who came out to my shows in Dublin.
I apologize for the lack of air conditioning.
Um,
I had such a great time and it's,
it's,
you know,
it's beyond a thrill to do what I do for a living and have people actually show
up and want to watch me do it.
Forget about when I leave my country in this people from other countries and
actually know of what I do and still want to come see me.
It's the fucking greatest thing ever.
And A,
I'm so psyched to get the first two under my belt.
I'm fucking ready to go tonight.
And Belfast,
I can't fucking wait.
And uh,
I'm a,
I'm swinging for the fences,
this whole fucking tour because I'm getting ready.
I'm getting ready for this.
I'm going to just be shooting another special,
I was fucking talking about Hillary last night,
blaming her for Bill Clinton.
Cheat not,
it was one of the most ignorant,
stupid fucking things that have ever sat on stage.
It was so fucking stupid.
People were basically just laughing at me knowing that I was being an ass.
And um,
I dunno.
It was kind of Nice to have that people use to do that a lot more in comedy
clubs before this stupid fucking,
I don't know what's going on right now,
if everybody taking everything so fucking seriously.
So anyways.
All right,
I'm babbling here.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Oh,
where will you be on Thursday?
I don't even know.
Belfast tonight.
Gallway Tuesday.
Wednesday.
I'll be in,
oh fuck.
I'll be in legendary,
legendary Manchester,
England.
Oh,
this is going to be awesome.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you Thursday.